hello welcome the game Scott's
continuing coverage of gamescom 2014 to
boise ID i'm here with brand town please
tell me about the wonderful world of
Metal Gear Solid phantom pain thanks for
that anyway at e3 we saw the first live
gameplay of the phantom pain today they
showed a pre-cut version of that same
mission but with a lot of different
let's say tactics that were used to
complete it from the beginning you know
we saw the horse defecation fujian is
that new now they showed it at e3 but
now they showed that that the horse poop
can be used to essentially send a
vehicle out in a spin incapacitating the
guys inside of it and then you can use
the folsom recovery system to whoop yeah
pick it up send it back to base alright
the Fulton recovery system and so from
there that you know he kind of went
about you know the mission in a
different way but we saw some other new
things like there were packs of wolves
that might be hunting sheep yes and so
one of the engines getting me the Sheep
is the Wolves won't actually pose a
threat to you which it sounds like they
will and we also learned that the AI
adapts now to what you do so you can you
know go to many different missions on
the same base kind of like in the ground
zeroes game and so let's say you spend a
lot of time tranquilizing soldiers in
the kind which is what they did at e3
which is what they did in three is but
everyone always does in though your
solid it's kind of like a tenant of that
game play soldiers soldiers will then
begin to wear metal helmets and you
won't be able to do that so you're gonna
have to change how you approach you know
the same level a part for me being a
different mission you really have to
play it differently anyway so from there
uh the enemies kind of spotted snake we
saw the cardboard box mechanic that was
showed off at sony's press conference we
did with the bikini-clad girl on the
front of it yeah which you know I mean
Miller solid is doing for being goofy
for me it takes me out of it yeah it's a
little strange it's just something with
the you know the horse poop was kind of
right there as well in terms of
craziness what's something latest this
year something a little bit seedy is
over the top of me and it's unbelievable
in a soldier will come up to a cardboard
box of a woman in just and literally
that just like gawking and any like like
Fulton them just yeah his pervert ass
editor but after that they showed a
really cool thing the enemy spotted
snake and they called in a helicopter
hmm and you know again the Fulton system
was shown in a new way so essentially
snake put a remote-control grenade on
the back of a jeep full ended up towards
the helicopter and then detonated a
grenade when the helicopter was there so
that's a new kind of way to take out
enemy helicopters but at that point they
knew this thing was that right yeah so
he took off on his horse and from there
he got in his helicopter and went back
to mother base but whose mother base did
he go back jon is right actually so what
they did was they cut to a competing
players motivates looked very different
from the 183 but one thing that we
noticed was that it had a it was no
longer the Diamond Dogs base it was the
the ravenous Raven it was definitely a
different sort of animal alliteration
yes and I saw a third one there yes
which is she yeah yeah so basically
players don't have to be part of Diamond
Dogs if they don't want to and this sort
of multiplicity of you know these groups
persisted again when snake was trying to
infiltrate this base and Seal back items
that were salt in his base but then was
spotted by another snake another snake
another scenario you saying there is a
second snake in Metal Gear Solid behind
the pain there's always a second thing
yeah but yes since was that other snake
voiced by David Hayter we couldn't
really get anything out of Konami
regards to this but that was the final
scene of the demo was one snake firing a
rocket at another if there if that does
not apply to the story in some way iona
be really disappointed because I think
there's the potential to sort of do
something interesting with the story
because right now is telling the tale
that's you know in the middle of two
games that already exist yeah and
something like that would add a new
element that really doesn't exist in the
storyline yet so who knows yeah maybe
we'll find out more TGS maybe we won't
but as a milling or solid fan I'm
intrigues and yeah that was pretty good
excellence well I guess stay Tooting our
coverage of gamescom 2014 for
information about other games you're
going to do just a couple of weeks
aren't you oh yeah oh yeah so stick to
the site for information I mega saw the
phantom pain for their
two